If I was a contractor and I wanted to make a 180k in the next 32 days to get myself a brand new truck, this is exactly what I would do.
You do not need to be working every single day on the field long hours.
To be completely honest, Engisys is not going to get you there, Watermouth is not going to get you there, and SEO is also not going to get you there.
What I would do instead is run high quality ads on social media in front of your right customers at the right time, at the right location, just like this one, this one, and this one.
You do not need a crazy online presence to achieve this.
As you can see, this person has 5 followers on Facebook, 160 followers on Instagram, and this is exactly how their campaign is looking at the moment.
69 leads in 32 days, 1,600 spent on ads, and a cost per lead of $24.
This is exactly what I did for our client.
That was actually one of our campaign's clients.
And just so you know, there's proof.
As you can see, he said 14,000 deal close, 22,000, 13,000, 60, 60, 13.
Thank you, Jay, just to confirm we're 182K for our first month.
He liked it so much that he even referred us to his buddies.
Now, if you're a contractor and you want me to do the same thing for your company, just comment the word ads, I'll reach out to you, and I'll help you out.